the libs have long endeavored to destroy
marriage and discourage people from
getting married unfortunately though
there's some people who are kind of on
the right
they're sort of vaguely on the right who
are also discouraging marriage now and
this is a very bad thing because I love
marriage and marriage is the fundamental
building block of society and marriage
as the symbol of the relationship
between Christ and his church so I think
marriage is really really important I
want to hear the strongest red pill
arguments
against getting married why you
shouldn't get married as a Young Man
guys you hit your Peak later in life
than women a man's Peaks from the age of
like 28 to 35 the longer you wait the
higher quality of a girl you can attract
once you have your business established
when you're making more money when
you're towards your Peak you're gonna be
able to pull a way hotter girl than at a
super young age waiting is not a bad
thing this will make sure you're happier
later on in life and you can pull a way
hotter girl that is not true because
merely pulling a hotter girl is not a
particularly strong predictor of
Happiness later in life and depending on
how much younger she is and how much
hotter she is and what her background is
um it might be quite the opposite is it
okay to date a guy for money yeah he's
right that men are more established and
probably more attractive to women
starting around their late 20s into
their early 30s that is true but what
are some better predictors looks fade if
you marry nearly for looks and you marry
a woman who's not virtuous and who has
all sorts of problems you're going to be
miserable for most of your life she's
going to lose her shine within the first
10 years of marriage probably so then
you got what 40 50 years there you're
you're not looking so great I once asked
my grandfather who was married to my
grandmother for almost 70 years what's
the key to a happy marriage this was on
the occasion of his 60th wedding
anniversary and he said patience shared
experience and he was a Navy Captain so
he said frequent absence helps you know
some of the worst advice I've seen and
this goes for women too is they say you
just need to totally establish who you
are before you meet somebody and have a
partnership with them the opposite is
true you and your spouse should be one
flesh and you should grow ever more
together and you're more likely to do
that
the younger you can get started and I
don't check on guys to get married get
married it's your prerogative I don't
give a I'm just saying me I truly
don't believe any man actually wants to
get married he wants his woman to be
loyal he wants his woman as a wife he
doesn't want to be a husband he just
wants to do it so she's less likely than
she it's a degree of insecurity and if I
marry her so no I really love her maybe
then she won't leave if you really know
you're going to leave you if you knew in
the Stars if God came down and said
she's never going to leave you never
leave you she's yours you own her soul
would you marry her no why she's mine
it's done I know my chick hate leaving
me my chicks ain't going nowhere so you
gotta am I marrying them so there
was a wise philosopher who once said
that he had 99 problems but it'd be
all of the things that can be difficult
or frustrating or annoying about dating
anyone just get multiplied when you have
when you have multiple girlfriends the
other reason that he's wrong about this
is if you are the sort of guy who just
sleeps around and pimps out women and is
a degenerate then you're going to have
the character of a degenerate this this
is why one of the advantages of marriage
is that marriage civilizes men it will
Tamp down your loss it will Tamp down
your selfishness it will give you
children who you can raise in a good and
virtuous and responsible way and it will
give you much much more joy ultimately
than your hedonistic single life people
are going to tell me I shouldn't have
children with multiple women my argument
to that is okay you got married
to this girl you were a husband she
left your ass and you got married at
this one and had kids now you have step
parents and all this messiness involved
well what if I was just a good father
and good husband to two or three and
they all looked up to Dad and I was
making all three of those families lives
10x would have been if they've got with
your lame ass or you think I don't
believe in family I believe in family 3x
more than you have three families and
you're gonna sit here on your moral High
ground and act like I'm a bad person and
you would never know you can't
yeah he seems like a lovely fellow
doesn't he seems like a really good role
model
at lunch Daddy can I go oh you can't he
says what if I'm a good father to these
three different families and you can't
be you can't having these three families
means that you are a bad father
and you're not irredeemable necessarily
but but you have done the wrong thing
and you've messed up people's lives and
so you should try to do the right thing
in as much as you possibly can apologize
he's right to point out that the modern
concept of easy no-fault divorce and
Blended families and all of that is
essentially tantamount to polygamy you
get the stepfather and the stepmother
and the step this and the stepdad and
the ex-spouse is not actually out of
your life you probably talk to that
person almost every day because you've
got to coordinate visits with the
children and child support and alimony
and visitation and this that and the
other thing and if you get remarried in
a civil way then you have another wife
or another husband and so yeah but that
doesn't doesn't make you worse than that
guy it's just the same thing it's the
same thing except in a way what he's
doing is worse because Aristotle has
these four kinds of people the
self-indulgent who do bad things and
love doing bad things the incontinent
who know they should do good things but
they do bad things out of weakness the
continent who know they should do good
things and they do good things but it's
a great struggle and The Virtuous who do
good things and love doing good things
they actually enjoy doing good things
the blended family is divorce type
people that those those would be the
incontinent what he's doing he's just
totally self-indulgent and vicious so
and in that way he's much worse and
shouldn't even get married to women I'm
gonna be honest I gotta be honest on the
show so mention again married to women
not in 2023 you there's no incentive for
you to get married to women there's no
benefit for you to get married to women
how do you feel that way it's not a
feeling it's it's a knowledge there is
no benefit name one benefit that a man
gets married women if you're not
factoring in your emotions then yeah
that makes sense what do you mean
is often known as a business proposal
put a pause there by whom by whom is it
even back in the olden days when when
marriages would be uh contracted for
political alliances or they never didn't
refer to it as a business it wasn't like
just a purely commercial clinical
Endeavor it's so low again name me one
benefit that a guy gets by marrying a
woman versus a serious relationship if
we take out religion first of all let's
take that out yeah
okay let's take out any sense of what is
good or bad or true or false or
beautiful or ugly let's just ignore that
so that we can what sit silently like a
bunch of deaf dumb mutes yeah okay
that's what we would have to do if we
actually took religion out of things me
getting married is not going to be on no
like a religious type thing it's more so
it's for me and my spouse because I
would want I want a wedding too I want
that commitment and that the reception
and I want all that just as much put a
pause there he's getting married because
he wants a wedding party
he wants to have a fancy dinner
so he's going to get married and then he
sleeps in he says I want commitment
why because it's good for you at least
okay why is it good it's better than not
commitment okay well if some things are
better than other things then that
implies that there's a maximum good
which is a religious
matter take out religion first of all
let's take that out it's not even their
fault that they don't know they've been
raised in an ignorant Way Family Law is
like the number one reason why you
should never get married
I'm not saying don't have kids I'm not
saying don't have a relationship with a
woman or women whatever your game
happens to be I'm not saying any of
those things all I'm saying is don't
ever live in a way that invites the
government to decide what happens to
your kids to put a pause there there is
no way of avoiding that it is inevitable
if you have a child out of wedlock the
government has exactly as much of a say
over your kids as as would have been the
case had you been married or married and
then divorced what this guy's saying is
basically don't get married
is if you get married your your wife
might leave you and then the family
courts might have a say over how your
kids are raised so instead just skip to
that part where the courts have to say
over how your kids are raised
up to the skin it's miserable part of
that and don't have any of the
even hope of having a good stable family
that doesn't sound like very good advice
do you want to be married good question
younger me would say no absolutely not
and the reason younger me would say no
is because I've come up with all the
arguments that there's no legal
Advantage really and the woman can wreck
you and you can lose all of your things
Etc but as I get older maybe I'm getting
a bit softer maybe I do think sometimes
you need to make a decision based purely
on love and have the faith of love and
faith in your love enough to say I don't
care what the government's going to do
about this because I truly believe in us
and I think we're going to make it would
I get married perhaps at some point yes
in the future I might get married yeah
that's good this is where maybe I'm
softer on someone like Andrew Tate than
a lot of people are because I think
there but for the grace of God go I and
you know I was an atheist for 10 years
and I I know I know how tempting all of
that is he's just been living in a kind
of an adolescence with all sorts of
horrible effects for the people around
him for a long time but that's true of a
lot of people in society and I I think
well if he's if he is sincerely going to
turn his life around and repent then
that's good he should do that it's never
too late to do that I'd never get
married no I don't see the Tactical
advantage to get married but it should
be a warning sign too I mean Andrew
takes a cautionary tale not just because
he got arrested by the Romanian police
but because of the kind of life he has
led for a very long time which is
dissolute and degenerate and harmful to
people and obviously not conducive to
Virtue or human flourishing it's good to
learn from your mistakes but it's much
better to learn from other people's
mistakes and
take these fellas it's a cautionary tale
okay that's it go get married have
children
[Music]